the left is arguing that this conflict
between Hamas and Israel is Trump's
fault because of the Abraham Accords
because it marginalized and sidelined
Hamas and their only reaction was going
to be military conflict and I'll push
back on that and say if Donald Trump's
policies were still in place then the
incentives of Saudi Arabia and qter and
the Emirates Etc would be to align with
Israel because their deal is being
jeopardized by the actions of Hamas
instead you get Joe Biden and his
administration that doesn't care for
these negotiations and wants War well
and that's exactly what happened right
you have Saudi Arabia which was doing
negotiations with Israel they were
cooling some tensions and now that has
totally been scuttled as a result of the
Hamas attack um so I think that's been
that's been pretty effective and if if
what the Biden Administration wants is
permanent War which it does seem like
that is what they're interested in um
then it would make sense that they would
continue to help escalate the situation